blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman i hope everybody had a good
memorial day
long weekend if you had one uh i
actually
had an anti-semitic incident over the
weekend someone hurling anti-semitic
abuse at me on the street i will tell
you that story later in the show
but i also came back from the break to
realize
that the treasonous and seditious
tentacles
of the trump administration continue to
grow and
spread donald trump's indicted and
pardoned former national security
adviser
michael flynn has been caught on video
saying that a coup like what happened in
myanmar
should happen in the united states
presumably
against the joe biden administration now
this is not
some random you know q anon shaman
wearing a weird hat
saying it this is a former national
security advisor to the president of the
united states flynn
said this sunday night during a q a
session at a conference called the
for god and country patriot roundup
in dallas texas there is a little detail
here that is just perfect which is that
the person
asking flynn the question doesn't even
know that it's myanmar instead he says
minamar
like every detail is harebrained the
focus is flynn's answer of course but
even the question is just you couldn't
write this stuff
i'm a simple marine i want to know why
what happened in minamar can't
happen here
yeah no reason i mean it should happen
here no reason
right that's right one more
it should happen here says a former
national security adviser to a president
of the united states
what happened in myanmar or minamar as
he said
a coup in myanmar started on the morning
of february first this year
when democratically elected members of
the country's ruling party the national
league for democracy
were thrown out they were deposed by the
tatmadaw myanmar's military
which then vested power
in a stratocracy and the country's
military executed a mourning raid
they detained the elected leader aung
sang
and other political figures the military
said what we did is right
because there was voter fraud
allegation in the myanmar november
election
so the link is of course the analogy
they claim exists with voter fraud
stealing the election from donald trump
in our november of 2020 election which
they therefore use to justify what
michael flynn says there should be a
coup
and joe biden should be deposed should
be forcibly removed
from the white house now remember that
these are the very people the loudest
ones screaming about how
they are patriots they have no actual
respect for the constitution
however they are the loudest ones
screaming about we are for the rule of
law it must be law and order but they
have no respect for the rule of law
they are attacking us from within
now as a practical question is this
beyond the limits of free speech because
it's an incitement to violence
a retired general that is so clearly a
traitor
and there is a key difference here
between the modern left and the modern
right
and it's important to talk about and
when when there are simil
when you can't tell the difference
between left and right we point it out
but where left and right couldn't be
more different we also point that out
when the people i vote for lose an
election
i don't like it but i don't say let's
overthrow the government
even when for years the russia probe
looked at whether donald trump was
helped by a foreign power in 2016
all of that stuff the left wasn't saying
let's do a violent insurrection
to remove donald trump and by the way as
far as flynn goes
who is even paying michael flynn now is
he does he have a pension from the
military if so
shouldn't this lead to you losing your
pension
is he getting paid for these one-off
appearances is someone
funding what he's doing and who even
would want to do that at this point in
time
not the best people that's for sure and
this is why down playing january 6th
is so dangerous if you downplay the
importance of january 6th
it makes escalation more likely it
welcomes the escalation
and when you hear a statement like this
from michael flynn
it shows that republicans have truly
learned nothing from the january 6th
trump riots and not only that it's
actually an escalation of rhetoric
and it's hard to know uh
what what what the the right really sees
as the next
step here with this stuff and in a sense
what republicans
have learned from january 6 so far
because
you know look look at what's taken place
so far they've learned that
nobody's really going to stop them and
it's not even clear there will be
consequences
if they do another version of january
6th so
now the trend that we're seeing is those
who have claimed for years to be about
law and order
and those who for years have pointed
fingers at antifa
and black lives matter and
eco-terrorists and the violent left or
whatever the case may be
those are the people who now are
regularly calling for violence
over the last few weeks and i want to
take a moment and look at
that trend now with this additional
example
of trump's former national security
adviser michael flynn
so we are seeing a trend of more and
more republicans calling for violence
while claiming
that the left is violent claiming that
they're for law and order
claiming people must follow the rules
claiming people must listen to police
and
all this stuff okay we now have had
three what i would consider prominent
calls to violence
from notable republican figures within
the last
week or two and this is this is just the
last again it's like 10 days or
something like that
and this is you know forget about the
fact that
if you visit the right wing pro-trump
enclaves of the internet
it's thousands and thousands of
individuals doing it as well
i'm focusing here on the fact that there
are prominent to semi-prominent
right-wing figures
that are now seemingly comfortable
publicly saying we we
should do violence we should do coups we
should do insurrections we should do the
second amendment
stuff in order to protect this or to
protect that okay let's start
we looked at this one last week or the
week before
fox news propagandist tucker carlson
calls for a real insurrection a
real insurrection the the framing the
and now the
illusion there being alluding to january
6 wasn't a real insurrection
but we probably should have a real one
remember this was about
completely incorrect claims about
immigration
from tucker's guest and this is how that
went down that
the people coming north from latin
america central america a lot of cases
are aware that there's a new
administration in the united states and
the policies are different
oh most definitely they're telegraphing
it down there uh
what do you when you see t-shirts with
people say buy them let me in
buy them let me and they're all over i
mean you know it's telegraphed back down
there one of them comes over and they'll
tell you
as soon as i get over and get through
i'm calling back home and i'm selling 10
more to come
that i got in come on we're sending a
message that hey
the border's open come on in do what you
want i mean
why aren't we enforcing the laws that
are on the book that are already on the
book that says
you can't cross that border illegally or
whatever but yet we're going to reward
you with
putting you in a nice hotel or or give
you a 1400 visa card
debit card that you can use while you're
here in the states you know until you
get established or whatever
and how many times they replenish what
do you mean give a 14 visa debit card
i i haven't been able to confirm this
yet but i have been told that they're
giving you
these immigrant families they're in
these hotels they're giving them a 14
i mean a 1400 visa card if they can why
don't we have a real insurrection
at some point like why why would we put
up with this well
in my opinion you're closer than you've
ever been in our country of getting to
that
i think we're closer i feel closer to
that i mean this is absolutely
it's it's beyond insulting that's the
type of thing
that is actually illiberal
anti-democratic authoritarian
uh escalation that we've been talking
about that's a perfect example right
there so there's tucker carlson
then we had matt gates the beleaguered
and disgusting congressman matt gates
said that we have an obligation this was
an event a few days ago we ever not we
they i guess have an obligation to use
the second amendment in armed rebellion
they must do it here is matt gates maybe
if you just conform
to their way of thinking a little more
that you'll be allowed to participate
in the digital world well you know what
silicon valley
can't cancel this movement or this rally
or this congressman
[Applause]
we have a second amendment in this
country and i think we have an
obligation to use it
nice one right i mean listen this is the
guy who says it's not okay to cancel
someone
twitter bands are over the line but
shooting others dead that's
okay that's a completely different thing
and that's something that he is going to
talk about
uh as adam congress as a congressman
adam kinzinger
said about that quote this is why we
need a january 6th commission
four months after an insurrection at the
capitol we're hearing this language at
another rally
where so-called leaders are stoking
fears
and anger and inciting violence
adam kinzinger is completely correct and
then we have the clip we looked at in
the first segment on today's show and
i'll play it again for you just to have
it all here together
donald trump's former national security
advisor yeah
former national security adviser michael
flynn calling for
a coup to be done against joe biden
at an event on a sunday evening i'm a
simple marine
i want to know why what happened
in minamar can't happen
[Applause]
here
yeah no reason i mean it should happen
here no reason
right that's right one more
a former national security adviser
calling for the forcible
removal of a president there
i still can't get over minamar they
don't even know myanmar
minamar they don't care what it's called
they don't need to know anything about
it
as long as they can use it somehow to
point to we should forcibly remove
joe biden these are calls to violence
period that's what they are they have to
be called what they are
the movement that insists we have to
call things what they are
that's them call this what it is just
call it what it is
a sitting congressman attempts to incite
acts of terror
a former national security adviser
encourages a coup
one of the most watched right-wing
propagandist media hosts
adopts the language of january 6th and
says let's do it for real this time
the january 6th one wasn't really an
insurrection but how about a real
insurrection and the right continues to
just edge
and push and prod and encourage their
people
towards launching some version of what
might look like a civil war
now in all seriousness maybe not with
the tucker carlson example
but certainly with the michael flynn
example and the matt gates examples
shouldn't the fbi be paying these guys
visits and i'm not saying
the fbi should harass people or look
into people for political reasons what i
mean is
if normal people said this kind of stuff
publicly it might actually be something
that gets them a visit from law
enforcement or
from federal agents why is that not even
in the picture when it comes to michael
flynn and matt gates and then of course
as i mentioned before
is michael flynn getting some kind of
pension from the military and if so
don't statements like these call into
question whether he should be receiving
that pension
and aside from the political piece
they're saying this stuff
as we have just mass shooting after mass
shooting in the united states
they barely even make headlines anymore
one big one last week in san jose did
make headlines but
in the week prior i think there were
something like 18
was it 14 14 or 18 mass shootings most
of i don't know where most of them were
they don't even make headlines because
it's just constant and then here is just
another angle on this
not necessarily ginning up the person to
person violence
that often is what we see in mass
shootings
but just generally building up this idea
of let's use violence let's use violence
to solve personal problems
let's us use violence to solve political
problems and hey if we bring guns in
as matt gates said even better because
we have the second amendment and that's
exactly what it should be for
incredibly dangerous stuff disgusting
stuff but
listen if you're these people if you're
these right wingers
who's going to hold you accountable no
we do we just we
can't make any progress on gun laws uh
we're
it's not really seeming like i mean okay
there's people there's individuals being
prosecuted for the role in the trump uh
riots but
systemically is there going to be any
consequence it doesn't seem like it why
wouldn't you do it
make sure you're following me on twitter
let me know your thoughts about this and
also make sure you're subscribed
to the new youtube channel
yes davidpakman.com packmanlive new
youtube channel
totally different content i'm inviting
you in
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show of course is
funded mostly
by great people like you who sign up at
joinpackman.com if you wanted to take
advantage of the memorial day special
and you forgot or you missed the email
or whatever
the code is memorial21 the discount is
so aggressive
i'm embarrassed to even say what it is
on the show
so i won't okay but that's the code
memorial21
you can use it on the membership of your
choice at joinpackman.com
all right i have to admit something to
you uh i was completely wrong
last year when i wrote off this q anon
conspiracy nonsense as a minor
passing transient insignificant movement
of no consequence whatsoever and my
mistake was
i overestimated the intelligence of the
american people
and this is not a country where you can
do that and end up
correctly assessing what's going on when
you overestimate
the intelligence of the american people
you end up with trump as president
right you say even republicans are never
going to make this guy their nominee
oh but they did well even americans
are not going to allow this guy to
become president like enough people will
come out to vote to
oh he's the president you get burned and
you end up very wrong and
uh case in point q anon conspiracy
theories have caught on to the point
that
twenty percent of americans one in five
americans believe
at least one q anon conspiracy theory
right now they may not consider
themselves
q anoners or whatever they call
themselves they may not even know the
origins of some of these conspiracies
but at least 20 percent of americans
believe
one or more of these conspiracy theories
p-r-r-i-i-f-y-c did a study
that was conducted during march it was
just released late last week
15 percent of americans agree with the q
anon statement that the united states
government media
and financial worlds quote are
controlled by a group of satan
worshiping pedophiles
who run a global child sex trafficking
operation
you go to the supermarket there's about
100 people in there
statistically 15 of them believe this
now of course if you're in
connecticut versus if you're in alabama
it's not going to be exactly 15 out of
100 but on a national
level 20 agree with the statement
there is a storm coming soon that will
sweep away the elites in power
and restore the rightful leaders twenty
percent believe that
fifteen percent of americans agree that
quote because things have gotten so far
off track
true american patriots may have to
resort to violence in order to save our
country and this relates to what
i said earlier about the right is
increasingly
vocal and willing to just straight up
call for violence and say
violence guns etc may or will be needed
this means that in total if you talk to
five random people on the street one
likely believes
some of these ideas now it's very
regionalized
if you do it in new york and
massachusetts it's not going to be one
out of five
if you go to georgia and south carolina
it's going to be more than one out of
five but on average around the united
states one in five people
believes at least one of these i i don't
even want to call them theories
not surprising findings are that those
who trust
far-right news outlets like oan and
newsmax
are more likely to believe this stuff
white evangelicals
are more likely to believe this stuff
and hispanic protestants
are more likely to believe this stuff
than americans in general now
the hispanic protestants one is is scary
you guys may remember that
right around the election i did a full
season i think it was
i think it was 13 episode 12 13 episodes
of
a show like mine but in spanish and it
was
and it was american politics but in
spanish for spanish-speaking american
residents
and the amount of conspiracy stuff that
i got was was stunning and even in some
groups i'm in
uh whatsapp groups and others spanish
speaking groups
there is a lot of this stuff shared
disproportionately
high if you're wondering how did we get
to this point
where 20 of americans believe at least
one of these conspiracies
it was a long process decades of the
republican war on education
you had this anti-intellectual movement
in the united states
with multiple i guess we would call them
fronts or battle lines you had
attacking education and teachers as
being liberal indoctrination attacking
college as being liberal indoctrination
underfunding public education at the
state level that's one
front starting to attack the credibility
of scientists and other experts we saw
this
with climate science that's a big big
deal same movement that said
you know during the must have been 70s
uh smoking's not actually bad for you
this type of thing right just creating
an
a a narrative that's anti-science
promoting the idea
of the wisdom of the masses so that when
something is popular they can point to
it and say this many people wouldn't be
wrong
and then of course the huge
infrastructure
of right-wing political news media and
i've talked about this for
so long they blur the lines between
opinion and news
they always have a counter narrative
they place
uh they they what should be nonsense
conspiracies relegated to
some website they place at the
equivalent level
on debates on fox news and newsmax and
oan and
talk radio and this has been the package
that we've seen as the republican party
has gone from starting to get a little
bit racist
during the civil rights era to reagan
and starting to be
anti-lazy welfare people and then
gingrich in the early 90s further
radicalizing them and getting away from
policy and starting to get towards
personal attacks george w bush the kind
of dim-witted dude
who who was starting to go in the
direction of making the republican party
really a party of cultural
values rather than policy obama comes in
and the racism coalesces
and then we get trump and we get
trumpian insanity and what we get now so
that's like 45 years understand that
the great sci-fi writer isaac asimov
said quote
there is a cult of ignorance in the
united states and there has always been
the strain of anti-intellectualism has
been a constant
thread winding its way through our
political and cultural life
nurtured by the false notion that
democracy
means that my ignorance is just as good
as your knowledge very appropriate for
what's taking place in the united states
right now now i don't think people are
willfully stupid not most people it's a
sort of
death of a thousand cuts type situation
the news itself on right wing media
gets more and more cultish the
advertisements are increasingly scams
alex jones is selling
supplements and weird cures fox news is
selling
pillows and gold bars all of this stuff
requires some gullibility
the ads you see on these channels and
the so-called news you see on these
channels
and then it just goes and goes and goes
further and then you get a candidate
like trump who says
let's coalesce all of the slightly
gullible people and put them together
and then that'll bring in even more
gullible people who say hey look all
these people can't possibly be wrong if
they like it
so these are folks who have completely
lost their grip on reality
completely and altogether and that's
really difficult to recover from
i'm not proposing solutions here because
i don't know what the solution is
but that's the problem and here's how
it's now manifesting
i have absolutely huge breaking news for
you
one of the biggest stories out there new
details have emerged
about hunter biden's laptop emails
just kidding i'm not an idiot but over
the memorial day holiday
fox news really did pretend to break
this explosive story about a conspiracy
theory
related to the president's son who has
nothing to do with his administration
whatsoever check this out it was maybe
not surprisingly
on fox and friends here we go new
details emerging in the hunter biden
scandal
email reportedly show a meeting between
his then vice president father joe biden
and
hunter's business partners from around
the world
yes so we must have had a lot of
translators there and two separate
dinners that are chronicled his laptop
as it becomes leaked out more and more
todd pyro joins us live
as the pot thickens and his dad's
presence as vice president
very present can you believe that guys
now
if you were paying attention all along
you'd know that they already
did this supposed exclusive in october
of 2020 it's now
seven or eight months old when fox
reported about quote
hunter's ex-partner recounts meeting
joe biden claims family paranoid
about hiding former vp's involvement it
was a non-story
outside of the fox news max conspiracy
universe
because there was no actual evidence of
anything untoward happening it's sort of
not
shocking that if it's true that joe
biden met people that his son worked
with
that that would that would be something
that takes place and and this is what
they cheered on
about trump trump made deals and his
kids are involved and everybody's so
good at business and trump helps his
kids and
isn't everybody so great at everything
but now if indeed it happened with joe
biden
then it's definitely bad it's definitely
very very bad
let's look at a little bit more of this
from the fox and friends report
and there's two separate meetings there
uh thanks todd how does he explain the
email of one of the guys at that dinner
thanking him an executive from burisma
thanking hunter biden for introducing
him to his dad
we get details uh it's in the new york
post today miranda devine's got a book
that's coming out in september it's
called laptop from hell
what's really curious okay now did you
see what steve ducey did there
this is a really important propaganda
technique to understand
you know how sometimes fox news will
insert opinion into news shows by
reporting on what tucker said the night
before
and then they react to what tucker said
during the opinion show
as if it's news that tucker said it
that's one technique fox uses to blur
the lines
between opinion and news uh reporting
the new york post has now run multiple
discredited stories on the hunter
biden laptop and the new york post is
owned by news corporation which also
owns fox news
so remember this the first hunter
biden story back in october was
published despite
fox news saying we're not going to touch
it and even some reporters at the new
york post saying we really shouldn't
publish this crap
it was widely reported on including by
the new york times as we're putting up
on the screen for you
and at the time fox did the same they
reported on
the new york post story in order to be
able to talk about it
without running the report themselves
which they said we can't run this this
is trash
fox decided let's just run the fact that
the new york post reported on it
and then that allowed them to do a week
of coverage here it's basically the same
thing
steve do see holding up the newspaper
from the new york post with the story
so of course with this new article we'll
see
whether the claims are even true but
remember
that the track record from the post on
these stories is highlighted by a salon
article from october
fox news rejected hunter biden expose
new york post writer refused to put
his name on it but then fox news
did weeks of coverage based on the very
new york post reporting
that fox news said we can't actually run
this this is no good this is how they do
it this is a technique you have to
understand
and it's important that as a savvy media
consumer
that we should all aspire to be to be we
not only identify the difference between
this is a news report and this is
opinion and of course they deliberately
blur that to make it difficult
but we also are able to distinguish this
is
a news report based on
a confirmed news report or this is a
news report based on something that is
essentially gossip
and that's an important distinction to
be able to make as well so we'll have
more on this
on our instagram make sure you're
following us on instagram at david
pakman show
and while you're at it follow me on
instagram at david.pacman
new backyard garden tour
some people get mad someone wrote to me
saying david how dare you show us those
disgusting stink weeds in your backyard
most people liked it though so there
will be a new garden tour on my
instagram
david.pacman
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent better
21.
it is a real pleasure to welcome to the
program today
noam chomsky one of the most renowned
intellectuals of our time and author of
over
25 books including chomsky for activists
universalizing resistance
uh professor it's so great having you on
today i appreciate it
very pleased to be with you so i would
love to start by getting your thoughts
about
how the the current state of the
american right
and the republican party got to where it
is today
there's this line that is sometimes
traced that goes back to
anger stemming from the civil rights
movement into
the reagan era of being against welfare
through to the gingrich era of the early
90s and radicalization
and this sort of progression that led to
the trumpian era how do you see this
progression of the last 40 50 years
that's a pretty accurate description
goes back to richard nixon
who recognized that
the republican party could pick up
uh southern democratic votes
by essentially being a racist
party didn't put it in those words of
course
but essentially by uh in various
indirect fashions making it clear that
they opposed the civil rights
movement the there had been a solid
democratic bloc of southern democrats
they were
strongly opposed to the johnson support
for the
early civil rights movement and this was
called nixon's southern strategy and
nothing secret about it
was quite open we have to recognize that
the republicans
have a certain problem
of the two political parties they are
the one
that is more supportive of
business rights and the very rich
and you can't approach voters saying
i want to support the very rich
and the corporate world and harm you
so please vote for me that obviously
doesn't work
so you have to look for other issues
what are called
cultural issues things that are apart
from the actual programs of the party
the programs of the party are very clear
strong support
for extreme wealth and corporate power
it's perfectly obvious during the trump
years
the one legislative achievement was a
tax bill that benefited the extreme rich
and extreme wealth and cutback of
corporate taxes
deregulation the sports business and so
on
you can't approach voters that way so
they've had to look for something else
well nixon's southern strategy was a
start
in the mid 1970s
leading republican strategist paul virus
who's a christian nationalist he
realized that
if the republicans pretended to be
opposed to abortion
i stress pretended that they could pick
up the
huge evangelical load and
make inroads into the northern catholic
food
so he proposed that to the party they
all switched on a dime
they had mostly been what we now call
pro-choice
when reagan was governor of
california in the 1960s passed a very
strong
pro-choice legislation
but in the mid 70s they all switched
entirely
reagan george h.w bush the whole slew of
them
so they became pretended anti-abortions
then the next thing was to pick up on
gun rights they're in favor of
guns they don't care one way or another
but that's the way you can pick up more
votes
and so it continues when reagan came
along
the party became pretty openly racist
reagan himself was a dedicated racist
he wasn't pretending so he
his uh he opened his campaign as you
recall in 1980
in philadelphia mississippi
town which is known for only one thing
civil rights workers were murdered there
the republicans pretended it was an
accident that nobody could miss it
yeah then came the stories about welfare
queens
black of course says stealing your money
and so on
in fact reagan was so racist that he was
the last
leader in the world to support the
apartheid regime in south africa
at a time when everyone else had left
thatcher
israel everyone reagan was still
supporting it
in fact as late as uh
[Music]
1988
it was all over by then the
reagan administration declared the
nelson mandela's african national
congress to be
one of the more notorious terrorist
groups in the world
and mandela himself was on the terrorist
list
couldn't visit the united states without
special authorization for about
20 years until congress finally passed
some
legislation about it well so
that's racism then comes gingrich
who reconstructed the
congress the republican congressional
delegation
so that it became kind of like the old
communist party
or it's a top-down organized
everyone has to agree its role is
obstructionist
that became open
not even hidden under mitch mcconnell
when obama was elected obama mcconnell's
came straight out and said
our task is to make sure he can do
nothing
we've just seen that again now
mcconnell's repeated the same point
we have to make sure we block him on
everything make the country ungovernable
and meanwhile the
policies of the polarity party have
changed as well so for example in
john mccain when he ran in 2008
had a a climate change
pro plank in his program
not not very far reaching but it was
there
and the republicans in the senate were
considering
climate change legislation the
koch brothers energy conglomerate had
been working for years
to ensure that the republicans would
never
veer towards recognizing global warming
and they were infuriated they launched a
huge
campaign major juggernaut
bribing senators is threatening them
with
primary challenges a huge lobbying
campaign
astroturf republicans totally changed
from that point on total climate denial
that's the way it stands today and
professor on that note you
i think this is a really important thing
particularly for my audience which is
mostly on the left to here
you mentioned john mccain in contrast to
some of these other wings of the right
there are some
who recently for example when mitt
romney
voted to convict donald trump on one of
those impeachment
accounts or when liz cheney was
removed from republican leadership
simply for saying
listen trump won we have to accept that
there are some on the left who have
reacted by saying
fundamentally these people are no
different
than the marjorie taylor greens and the
most extreme of the republican party
while others believe
no there is an important difference
between people like mccain and romney
and those that have taken over the party
now do you believe that the difference
is a materially significant difference
there is a difference and
mccain had whatever you think about his
policies i didn't like him i mean
but nevertheless he was sort of a human
being
decent human being in some ways had some
degree of integrity
yeah that's disappeared from the party
i mean when you look at them now they're
virtually all
in terror before the trump rebel
you can just see it in every act that
they make
blocking the inquiry commission the
votes on
i mean the votes on the stimulus were
quite interesting the republican party
the legislators know very well
that their own constituents favored
largely favored the stimulus
they themselves largely propose support
them
but they voted as a block uniformly
against it you have to the highest
priority is make the country
ungovernable
prevent anything from happening find a
way to get back into power
so we can then worship trump and
go ahead to destroy the world i mean
trump's
climate change policies alone forgetting
everything else
another four years of that would
probably carry us to irreversible
tipping points the game could very well
be over
and if you look at the republican base
they're
caught in this trap a kind of an echo
chamber trap
they hear the republican leadership
now it's trump worship they they turn on
the fox news
reiterates it it's an echo chamber uh
listen to it rush limbaugh when he was
alive he tells them
same thing take a look at the attitudes
it's terrifying for example there was
recently a
pew poll the main polling agency
studies public attitudes they ask people
a simple question here they give them
15 choices of to rank
as which were the urgent problems that
we have to face
a split between democrats and
republicans
among republicans the lowest
of the 15 was climate change
14 thought that was a serious problem
the highest problem greatest problem we
face is
illegal immigration and the deficit
the deficit became a problem on november
4th
indeed for that it was fine the line was
reagan taught us that deficits don't
matter
so trump punched a huge hole in the
deficit that was fine
but november 4th the democrats the
deficit is the highest problem we face
and whatever you think about illegal
immigration it's
i mean there are problems but it's
nothing remotely like
globally warming which is going to
destroy organized human life on earth
but that's 14 the lowest of all the
problems
well you put yourself in the position of
a
republican voter you can understand it
you hear trump you hear the republican
leadership
you listen to fox news they say it's
just a liberal hoax
maybe the chinese are doing so what do
you want to believe
that's a really you're faced with a
really serious problem
the republican party has just gone off
the rails
even the mainstream commentators
described them as
a radical insurgency with his abandoned
parliamentary politics and you can see
it in
the actions particularly since gingrich
bastard
mcconnell and the full interview with
noam chomsky continues and will be
posted to our youtube channel
today at youtube.com the david pakman
show
we will go to a break and continue right
after this
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him okay let's follow up
about a couple of stories from last week
as many of you know if you watched last
week radical republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor green
equated wearing a mask on the floor of
the house of representatives
to how jews were killed during the nazi
holocaust of world war
ii this was a completely outrageous
comment
and not even that many republicans
criticized her for it most of them
staying silent
but now she's just denying that she ever
said it she was on the dr
gina prime time program on real
america's voice network
i have no idea what that is either and
she said you know really i wasn't
comparing anything to the holocaust and
it wasn't about masks or
something i don't even understand let's
take a look at it together and see if we
can figure it out
i'm going to continue to fight back
against speaker mass coal
that's what i call speaker pelosi
speaker maskhole and her ridiculous
tyrannical mass policies but the biggest
outrage is people being treated like
second-class citizens
um simply because they refuse to to uh
show a past passport a vaccine passport
and i had compared it to to the way the
the horrible way
that um jewish people had been treated
by having to show their papers of who
they are
well without a phone call or a text
message all of a sudden i find out on
the news
that kevin mccarthy um elise stefanik
and
and unfortunately steve scalise had all
condemned
my remarks and in their own own
condemnation
of my remarks they didn't even have it
right what i had said in the first place
they were just uh misstating things i
had said
and then also they were just preaching
the the woke media
mobs uh talking points so this is this
is a problem they didn't have to attack
me
nancy pelosi doesn't attack her own and
i think the gop needs to do better
so what was the message you were trying
to convey there
well the message is this we don't need
to have americans treated like
second-class citizens
simply because they don't want to get
the vaccine the vaccine is not even
fda uh certified yet it hasn't been
approved by the fda
but yet we have schools like the
university of virginia
telling their students that they can't
return to in-person classes
without getting the vaccine well that's
a violation of their freedoms their
rights and their hipaa rights
uh schools and universities should not
step in
especially when there's side effects
being shown with these vaccines
and it's not fda approved and people
have the right to choose especially
young people
that are in the lowest risk group and
don't need the vaccine anyways most of
them do not
um freedom is so precious we have to
protect it
uh but we can't allow the democrats and
those in charge
um that think they know better than us
and and think they can control
everything that we try to do in our
daily lives we can't allow them to force
us into socialism
and and having a tyrannical government
we have to stand up against these
aggressions and it's it's important that
we speak out and do that
and so you do reject the media narrative
or accusation i guess that says you
compared wearing a mask
to the holocaust you say that's that's
untrue that's not at all what you meant
by that
oh it's completely untrue um anyone can
ask david brody he was
he was interviewing me at the time when
i made those statements and i wasn't
even talking about
mass per se it was it was talking about
the mistreatment of being treated like a
second class citizen
and i never said the word holocaust it's
just the same as i never said the words
jewish space lasers but then the media
made that one up too
she is just so gross i mean just really
a disgusting person now of course she
did say it
here are her original comments let's
take a look and you're going to notice
if you're of normal
english proficiency it's really clear
what she's saying
it's really clear what she meant this
woman is mentally ill
you know we can look back in a time in
history where people were told to wear a
gold star
and they were definitely treated like
second-class citiz citizens so much so
that they were put in trains and taken
to gas chambers
in nazi germany and this is exactly the
type of abuse that nancy pelosi is
talking about
so she's claiming i guess that
because in that segment we just watched
she didn't use the word holocaust
that the entire comment really was not
equating mass squaring to what was done
to the jews during the holocaust but
marjorie when you talk about trains
taking jews
to gas chambers in nazi germany
that's the holocaust that that was
during world war ii it's just what it is
using the word holocaust or not doesn't
really make it any different
and it's also extra wacky that just a
few days ago she was defending this she
was doubling down she was saying yeah i
said it
and then now she said that's not
actually what i said it's certainly not
what i meant
whether she knows this or not this is a
technique called the fire hose of
falsehood now
it's not to be confused with gaslighting
it's related to gas lighting but it's
not exactly gas lighting
not to be confused with the gish gallop
it's related to the gish gallop but gish
gallop is when you say a bunch of
different things
during a debate particularly when
there's limited time and it makes it
difficult to refute you the fire hose of
falsehood
is where you just claim different things
at different opportunities
trump did this all the time he would
take every position on an issue
over a period of a few days the issue
was china trump would say one thing
about china during a debate
and then he would say something
different about china on fox news the
next day
and then he would tweet something
different about china on day three
and number one it makes it difficult for
us to suss out what is this person's
actual position what are they actually
claiming
and it also makes people sort of give up
on trying to figure out what the truth
is because it just seems all so
complicated
and then lastly it's also a technique
that increases the likelihood
that anybody can find one of your
positions that you like
trump would do this for example on um i
think this was on abortion
remember when on abortion he i'm
thinking back to 2016
he was asked uh should the woman i'm
against abortion
okay should the woman be punished if she
gets an abortion and he said
well yeah she should and then a lot of
pro-lifers love that
and then the next day he said yeah
actually that's not really what i meant
and so like no matter what your position
is you could find
an instance of trump saying something
that you probably liked and just say
listen he did say that one thing there
so i think i agree with him on this
issue um
this is the sort of this is how you
weaponize
this information and if you remember
that quote from trump
uh about you can't believe what you're
seeing um the exact quote was
stick with us don't believe the crap you
see from these people the fake news
what you're seeing and what you're
reading is not what's happening
that is the sort of full conclusion of
the weaponization of disinformation
telling people even your own
senses betray you just listen to me well
what if you're saying
something different every two days just
listen to me
it's a smart strategy when your voters
are so clueless
do and say horrible things and then
pretend they never happened
because it muddies up the message and
that's what marjorie taylor green is
doing they get the info
out to the people they are targeting but
then they do their best to walk it back
and end up suffering no repercussions
think of it like posting retractions in
a newspaper
that almost nobody notices after your
lead story
has already had the impact you wanted to
have that's what they're doing that's
what marjorie taylor green either
i'm not even saying she's doing it out
of a calculation
um but uh it does work
when your constituents are marjorie
taylor green's constituents
all right let me talk about something
that that happened over the weekend
um as many of you know uh when the
latest
israeli-palestinian flare-up
took place um at first
for the first four or so days i i didn't
say anything about it
feeling i didn't really have too much to
add i heard from some people
respectfully who said hey you should
talk about this
um and then so i did and i did a
20-minute segment it's over the last
month it's the only 20-minute segment
i've done and that was a couple of weeks
ago and throughout
before i talked about it and after the
anti-semitic comments raining down on
our youtube channel
raining down on twitter instagram we
we've had to block
tw twitch thousands uh close to a
thousand people i would say i don't want
to exaggerate
certainly hundreds of people on youtube
about a hundred on uh on twitter
call it 600 to 800 people probably okay
to not not be hyperbolic which is
you know a lot for a program our size
and even after i did the segment
the anti-semitic comments about me being
a jew rat
or all of this different stuff they just
didn't stop and at a certain point it
sort of becomes clear that you're not
really
contacting me about foreign policy
anymore it's just anti-semitism that's
really what it
is this crossed over to the real world
and
over the weekend i was um out with some
friends for dinner
uh at um at a restaurant
and we were there sort of a lot of
things are still closing early in the
northeast
um because of covet guidelines and so
there were very few people left
and as i was leaving um i walked by
someone
who kind of gave me a weird look and i
didn't know if it was that
you know i had some borscht on my face
like that one time where i did an entire
show with
with borscht on my face and producer pat
didn't tell me or maybe they recognized
me i didn't really know
walked past them and when i'm 30 feet
away
i hear pacman and i turn around
and they yell at me you jew
zionist imperialist
now i just turned and walked away i
didn't engage with it and i think in
general
what these people want is a reaction
and who knows if they plan to film me
and put it on twitter or whatever the
case
um but i just i just walked away
and you know this what what's really to
obviously this is not fun um but
people come up to me all the time and
typically they're
they're positive experiences and i do a
show that's public and so
to some degree this is this is bound to
happen but
um you know this is this was a quote
left winger
right this this is not a right winger
this is an issue that it's it's more
often the left
the right does a lot of anti-semitism
with me but they say go back to israel
right the right-wing anti-semitism is go
back to israel a place i've been once in
my life for
nine days um the this is this was some
something from the left
and so i think it should be clear to all
of us at this point
that this is not a critique of my
position
right it's not it's not even really an
argument as many of you know
uh i have more than a decade on record
of being
unquestionably critical of uh
settlements
the netanyahu administration the urgency
with which we need to find a way to lift
the blockade
i'm not going to do the segment and see
this is the problem
why am i even talking about policy
because this incident was not about
policy
i've spoken about you know the
israeli-palestinian conflict
really once in the last two years and so
jew zionist imperialist is not even
plausibly
a critique of my policy and uh
all sorts of things are going off here
so what do we do about something like
this
i don't know i don't really plan to do
anything about it um
there's a there's a real problem with
anti-semitism on the right and we've
covered it for a really long time we
just reviewed on a recent live stream
uh that white nationalist dude who
wanted craig cobb who wanted a whites
only enclave in one of the dakotas
and he was overtly anti-semitic during
our interview and that's very clearly a
right-wing anti-semitism
unfortunately there's a left-wing
anti-semitism as well
and uh even by talking about this
there's going to be even more that's
hurled at me and
some people are going to write and say
well it's not anti-semitism david
because you are a zionist and as i've
always said before
what do you even mean by that term every
time i've been confronted with it
um i never really get a straight answer
and what i've said before is if what
you're asking me
is do i think that the solution to the
israeli-palestinian conflict
is no more israel no i don't think
that's the solution
much like the solution is not no no
palestinian state
right i think the solution is an israeli
state in a palestinian state
does it does that make me a zionist uh
because otherwise it's never anything
we're able to actually figure out but
hurling jew
zionist imperialist to someone you know
on the street
um is uh is is over the line it's not a
policy critique
i don't know what else to say about it
but if the left goes
too far in this direction
it's not going to be good and as i said
before
it's counterproductive it's
counterproductive because
every time jewish folks hear
about not what happened to me what
happened to me was not violent it wasn't
physically violent but what we
the videos we saw from los angeles new
york etc
more and more american jews or jews
wherever they're being harassed in
france
say wow i really may need to move to
israel someday
and they disengage from holding
israel accountable for the things israel
does wrong so not only do i think it's
ugly and disgusting
it's also counterproductive to what most
of these leftists claim to want
i think that's all i really feel the
need to say about it
um maybe something i'll follow up on at
some point in the future but
really ugly stuff unbecoming unbecoming
of the left
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p here's a great question about
the origins of anti-vaxxer ism
take a listen hi david my name is
caitlin and i'm from florida and i have
a question for you about
vaccine hesitancy so in rare florida
fashion
i have a mom who is a trumper
and an anti-doctor and happens to think
that
since i'm on the pre-med track i need to
be wary of the mark of the beast
and getting microchipped with a vaccine
so
obviously she's not very fond of the
idea of getting the copa 19 vaccine
although
the majority of her family members have
already gotten the vaccine and are doing
just fine
so i wanted to know your opinion on
where you think all of this
anti-vaxx sentiment originated like is
there just
some point in history where this kind of
became really prevalent in the united
states
yeah so listen this is so mark of the
beast specifically
is a christian uh thing so so mark of
the beast is based on
particular christian teachings i don't
know what they are i don't really care
but that that's that
the origin the first real big
anti-vaccine movement was in england
around smallpox so you had the
anti-vaccination leagues
there were some who had religious
objections to the smallpox vaccine
some who had what they claimed to be
scientific objections some had political
objections and um the
the that that's the origin in england
now in the united states i believe in it
was in the early 1900s like 1902 1903
there was a smallpox outbreak and you
had the board of health
in cambridge massachusetts mandate
vaccination for
all residents and some people went
absolutely nuts
and there were similar arguments there
were so-called medical arguments made
there were religious arguments made
there were political freedom arguments
made so you had that
and then you just saw basically
repetitions of that in the mid
70s with the dtp diphtheria
tetanus pertussis vaccine
you had a similar kind of controversy
many of you might remember
in the late 90s there was the mmr
measles mumps rubella
controversy and dr andrew wakefield who
was disbarred
uh or or deboarded i don't know what it
would be called who claimed that there
was a connection between
autism and the mmr vaccine um so then
that built it up further and then now
the the thing now is that it's the
perfect storm because because of the
right winger
uh insanity on kovid
you basically weapon not weaponized the
pre-existing ignorance and conspiracism
of trump supporters
and it's now being applied heavily to
the covet vaccine so it's like the
perfect storm but
those are the origins and it goes back
quite a ways and it's absolutely
horrifying
we have a great bonus show for you today
i won't even tell you what it'll be a
surprise
it's just a great bonus show sign up at
jointman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman